for some perspective on all this we turn
to the Washington Post amber Phillips
she writes about politics for the
newspapers political analysis blog the
fix amber good morning good mornin help
me out here amber because I'm a little
puzzled by this week and because it
looked like there were the white house
that had a number of opportunities to
put a period on this whole thing and
elected not to exactly I think this
started this whole thing started Monday
when a reporter asked President Trump
why haven't you spoken out publicly
about these four men who died in Nigeria
go at that date president Trump reacted
the way he always does when he feels
like he's in a box which is to get
defensive right away and attack
politically and in that attack he
obviously accused falsely President
Obama and former presidents of not
making calls and all of this set the
stage are really primed it for like a
political battle to just blow up over
this incident and that's what we sell
Tuesday in in a totally separate
incident with a phone call as phone
service numbers and and now we're ending
the week with Democratic lawmakers
calling the white house full of white
supremacist and the White House reacting
by saying how dare you question in
general and it just kind of is all
degraded so quickly amber how much of an
issue is this for general Kelly who thus
far has been almost the the most
untouched member of the Trump
administration the fact that he did get
the story wrong about congresswoman
Wilson is that an issue for him going
for right yeah I think that his
reputation has been dinged this week
because you're absolutely right Alex
like he was perceived has someone who
came in to help straighten up the White
House right to help keep the president
out of this exact kind of political
feuds we're talking about and here he is
injecting himself in the middle of it
and as you said making false claims in
the process and doing a very trumpian
thing quite frankly of refusing to back
down when it gets facts wrong it's a
remarkable thing for this general that
doesn't really match up with what we
know of him and who gave some incredibly
moving anecdotes and testimony about
what it is like to lose a son in battle
you did know meanwhile Thursday night
Senate Republicans passed the fiscal
year 2018 budget resolution which now
allows the GOP to move forward on tax
reform without Democratic support or
threat of a filibuster correct correct
we're exactly where we were when
Republicans are trying to pass Obamacare
it failed it failed and it is a very
real possibility this exact same thing
could happen with tax reform and here's
why they're trying to do it without
Democratic votes and so they're kind of
locked into this procedural box where
they can only spend a certain amount of
money in this case it's a lot of money
for conservative Republicans one and a
half trillion dollars they can spend on
these tax cuts that cuts out a lot of
potential votes that they might need
from house conservatives perhaps
moderate commader 'its they're gonna say
well you know what I want to spend that
money but I don't want to cut taxes here
or there and I and I think we have a
long way to go before any kind of tax
bill is a reality right we haven't even
seen a bill let alone tax legislation
passing Congress just along Republican
votes and getting to the presents amber
I mean the Republican Party has very
publicly said we are going to get this
done before the end of the year what is
the political fallout if in fact they
don't get it done before the end of the
year it's impossible to imagine a major
piece of legislation happening in an
election year right exactly a GOP
analysts I talked to who are trying you
know behind the scenes to try to keep
Republicans in control Congress are
really really worried they say the best
thing you can do politically is pass
legislation that gets more money into
people's pockets and and for Republicans
gets government you know kind of out of
people's lives on taxes especially the
worst thing you can do is make a promise
and not deliver on it and you're
absolutely right Alex that the clock is
ticking because by next year whatever
you know kind of beliefs that all these
Republicans have they're gonna be more
entrenched right they're not going to
want to back down and take tough votes
in an election meanwhile this bill or
amber is largely being fashioned behind
closed doors that we know you know
there's it's being hammered out and we
don't know what's in it I feel like
we're deja viewing the whole Obamacare
yeah the great Yogi Berra yeah we don't
know what's in the bill we do know that
there would probably be some tough tough
decisions on how to pay for a bunch of
tax cuts that the White House and
Republicans proposed in September and a
blueprint because budget experts
estimate that's like upwards of three to
five trillion dollars worth of tax cuts
that's really hard for the Republican
Party to say oh we're gonna blow a hole
in the deficit for that so they've got
to make some really tough decisions on
how to pay for that Amber Phillips
thanks for being with us this morning